[SOUND] How many of you
have found yourself in
the situation where you're talking
to someone from another country, or
from another culture,
even from another state or city,
that you don't quite get what they're
saying and you're just kind of confused?
Cameron's raising his hands.
You're kind of clueless and sometimes you
just, you don't know what's going on.
Well, we're here to talk to you today
about cross-cultural communication.
And we think it's a very important
topic to the four of us and
we hope it's valuable to you as well.
So, first thing we want to show you is
cross-cultural exchanges everywhere.
And some put of a little bit funny
picture there but it show you that even
simple places like a market, remote place
in China that it still exists as well.
But so the point here is, did you know
that translation services is actually
a $40 billion industry and
it's growing 8% a year?
Did you know that 40% of your classmates
here are from another country?
Did you know that also terrorism and
cross-border commerce and
all the things required nuanced
to cultural understanding?
That's sometimes actually
beyond the simple language.
And what I'll show you here is a picture
of George W with King Abdullah from Saudi.
You might find that strange but
it's actually in their customs to
hold hands while two mens talk.
It just goes to show that it is really
a powerful aspect of communication
that all this cultural differences
underline what we say.
So, the things we also want to point
out is we haven't had a session on
cross-cultural communication
from this class so,
I think it is under-appreciated
in some sense.
And sometimes, we all speak English
here obviously have GSB but
it really delight some of
the underlying differences that people
don't really express from
a purely linguistic perspective.
And the second last point is really some
of these things are very hard to know
because we are talking to
someone from another culture.
They don't really give you a lot of
feedback or we lose attention on them.
They don't really give you, hey, sorry,
I didn't understand, that's very rarely
happens unless you guys are really close.
So, but the good news for
all of you guys is we are here to help.
So today,
we are going to talk to you guys about
some of our personal stories from
the past, what we experienced,
and hopefully bring to you what
JD terms conscious incompetence.
So, you're aware at least when you're
talking to someone from another culture
that some things are not going across.
And lastly, we're going to offer
you some advice and tips so
you guys have a sense of, one maybe small
things we can do to be very effective.
So with that, I'm going to pass off to
Funso who's going to talk to you about
some of the verbal
communication challenges.
>> Yes, so, what we want you to take
away from this class is to stay lit.
We want you to listen, inquire and
test things out whenever you're talking to
people who are from different cultures.
But before we even do that,
what are some things that might
get into the way of that?
Well, in Fred Jandt's book,
An Introduction to
Intercultural Communication, there
are three things that we consider to be
barriers to communication when it
comes to the aspect of listening.
The first one is anxiety and
how many of us have traveled the world and
got into a new country,
we're not really sure of the norms are,
we're not really sure of the culture is or
how to shake hands or do those things.
Anxiety is the number one
reason that people impacted and
affects people's communication
across cultures.
A second one is judging other
groups by your own culture.
I mean, this may seem common sense,
but you might think that everyone does
the same things or acts the same way that
you do when you go into a new environment.
And that's another reason why people
have found it really challenging to
communicate with people in other cultures.
A third reason is,
is the same language different meaning.
I mean Jeff speaks English,
I speak English.
Ashton, the other cohort, speaks English.
But I'm speaking
Nigerian/American-English,
she's speaking British-English, and
Ash is speaking Australian-English.
We're all speaking the same language but
there are different words
that mean different things.
And it's important to be very aware that
you might be using the same words but
to understand that there might be
deeper meaning in those words.
And so, to bring it back to the GSB,
what are some common mishaps that happen?
I mean, how many of us have been in
a class where someone has said something
go ahead and break a leg?
I remember the first time I came to
the US and someone told me to do that,
I was really concerned and
backed away slowly.
>> [LAUGH]
>> But
that's not what that means an incur event
maybe you're about to go on a show.
But these are their idiomatic
expressions such as this that
if your coming from another country you
may not be very familiar what that means.
And it's important to recognize that
you may have to explain that to
another person.
Another expression is references.
A professor in class asks someone
a question, to which no one answered.
And she proceeds to say, Bueller, Bueller,
Bueller, who knows what I'm talking about?
This is a reference to
Ferris Bueller's Day Off.
Now, in a class like this where,
the class is 40% international,
you may not know what that means.
And you've lost 40% of your class,
and they are lost,
they've missed the entire message of
what you're trying to get across.
We're very guilty of this, especially at
the GSB, and it's very important to be
aware that when you make movie or
TV or even sports references, and
not everyone's going to understand
what you're referring to.
The third one are nonexistent words.
And what I mean by that is for
example if you're speaking Spanish,
there's a word that's using Spanish,
but the word does not exist in English.
Those are very difficult to transfer
from one language to the other, and
if you find a word that's very close,
some of that meaning is also lost so,
being very aware of what that means.
So that's it for verbal communication,
remember to stay lit and
I'll pass it on to Willem.
>> So, when I was five years old,
my family moved from the US to Mexico,
we made wonderful Mexican friends there.
They taught us local customs,
traditions, and then, gestures as well.
Some of these gestures included thank you,
and
[FOREIGN] which is also kind of a lot,
or it can also mean it's crowded here.
So then, about a year and a half later,
we picked up and moved to Argentina.
And this is a picture of a very
famous place in Argentina,
it's also one of the worst intersections
you can imagine for traffic.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Here lanes mean effectively nothing,
direction of travel is
kind of a suggestion.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And
one day my father was driving my
brother and I along this road and
by some weird fluke some guy stopped
to let us merge in front of him.
Father who was confused but grateful and
gestures what he believed to kind of thank
you a lot and it's also crowded here.
So, he thinks this is like
the perfectly efficient use of gesture.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And from one second to the next,
this guy goes from this calm,
relaxed guy letting us in front of him,
to just kind of maniacal
road raging monkey man,
who jumps out of his car beating on
the hood and the windows of our car.
>> [LAUGH]
>> [LAUGH] So, at this point,
I'm really thankful that when my father
steps out of the car his physical
stature alone is enough to
kind of resolve this issue.
>> [LAUGH]
>> But later that night,
we learned that to Chileans,
of whom there are many in Argentina,
the Mexican [FOREIGN] is actually
[FOREIGN] which is frequently used
as [FOREIGN] or directly
translated as your mother's shell.
>> [LAUGH]
>> So,
I will let you all think
about the details there.
But this was an example of a dangerous
assumption you don't want to
make about nonverbal communication.
So, while it can be an extremely
effective and useful tool,
I urge you all to be both aware and
respectful of not only the obvious
differences in kind of personal space or
gestures although, I guess not that
obvious to my father or eye contact.
But also kind of more subtle and
nuance differences in the cultural
understanding of time,
kind of a pace of activity, and the use
of silence, and also the use of touch.
So, with that,
I'm going to turn it over to George.
>> Thank you, Willem.
>> [LAUGH]
>> That was the Mexican thank you,
not a suggestion about Willem's mother,
who I'm sure is a wonderful lady.
Has anyone in here ever used a translator,
anyone?
It's a very interesting and
challenging experience.
I was in the military and
I served in the Middle East and then,
in Southeast Asia, and a lot of partners
that we worked with to mentor and
conduct their own missions
didn't speak English.
They either spoke,
a language of Afghanistan, or Tagalog,
which is a language in
the southeastern Philippines.
So, I've often found myself
dealing with translators.
And so, the tools that I'm going to
share with you today are things that I
learned the hard way through a lot of
sweat, and tears, and embarrassment.
One of those that I'd like to highlight
is that humor doesn't translate
nearly as well, and
through another language, particularly
through the filter of a translator.
If you can imagine the downside of really
offending someone in another language
is huge, and trying to get a small chuckle
out of someone isn't even worth the risk,
my advice to you, don't try and
make a joke through a translator.
Something that I am very guilty of,
is when I would have meetings,
I would speak to my translator and
I would lose rapport with the audience
that I was actually trying to speak to.
So, maintain a conversation and
eye contact with one individual as he or
she was meant to translate
to the audience.
And I completely isolated and
marginalized this person because
I focus on the translator.
So, I encourage you, if you're
ever using a translator, in fact,
just be mindful to maintain rapport and
body language and
eye contact with your intended audience,
not your translator.
Something that to me seems
intuitive as I looked back and
having made these mistakes,
is something about preparation.
Sit down and
present with your translator, or
share your slides with your translator
prior to the actual event so
that they can proofread and help you out
and actually you own your own message.
Something that's unique about translators
is that you think you have your own
microphone.
But what the audience actually hears is
the translator's message, not your own.
So, if you're going to own your message,
make sure that you
craft it exactly how you want it and
practice with your translator.
There's a number of other things that I
have stories I would share with you, but
we're running out of time.
One of those is around jargon
in colloquial phrases.
I think we've learned a lot about that
this morning, through Willem's gestures
as well as the sports metaphors but
I just want to reiterate it.
Don't try and make a colloquial
phrase through a translator,
because it just isn't going to work well.
And so, when it comes to translators and
then, wrapping it up,
what we really want you guys to take away
is this cute little acronym we devised to
stay LIT, really do listen,
inquire, and test.
Anytime you're going to be
communicating cross-culturally.
And lastly, we want to serve as resources
for all of you going forward so,
I've listed our contact
information behind us and
some of the geographies that
we've exposed ourselves to.
So, if you ever find yourself either
throughout your career at the GSB or
after business school going to one of
these geographies, drop us a note and
we can give you some of the stories and
lessons that we've learned the hard way so
that you don't make the same
mistakes that we did.
[MUSIC]